- I don't fuckin' complain.
- No reason to, right?
- You know what?
When you're young you have stuff
to complain about 'cause you got
it all figured out life.
Once you get close to 40 years
old it's like fuck and your
friends start dying of
natural causes and shit.
Like I had a friend, 40 years
old died in his fucking sleep.
In shape, buff as shit, never
smoked or drink in his life,
eats fucking, you know, like
salmon and vegetables and shit
and he just fucking died, man.
- You know my friend
Dustin who's coming by?
You guys know who
Howard Bingham is?
- Yeah.
- Famous photographer.
- So, Howard
Bingham's son, Dustin,
I went to college with.
He's one of my best friends,
coming by and his brother,
Daymond, who did the Ali movie
with Will Smith passed way in
his sleep. It's crazy.
Ali died, Daymond died and
Howard Bingham died as you might
of saw all within like a year.
It all fucking sucks.
- So again, so getting
back to what we're saying--
- Yeah.
- ain't gonna complain.
- Yeah, man.
- You wake up, you're alive.
I wouldn't give a
fuck if you were a bum.
Like you wake up you're alive
and not in prison for the
rest of your life
like you have options.
- 400 trillion to 1.
You know that's my...
I talk about it everyday.
- Yeah.
- When I think about
the fact that my dad coulda,
you know, decide to take a shit
and do you know how hard it is
to become a human?
- [The Game] Exactly, yeah.
- 400 trillion to 1.
Like there's no math.
Like you could win 98 NBA
championships in a row more
likely than being a human being.
(light music)